Professor Ben Polak:
So last time we covered a
whole bunch of new ideas,
and it was really quite a lot
of ideas for one class.
Here's some of the ideas we
covered.
We talked about information
sets, and these were ways to
allow us to model imperfect
information.
So what's imperfect information?
It's a way of being able to
capture both simultaneity in
moves and sequential moves in
the same game.
So it's a way that's going to
allow us to meld the lessons
from before the mid-term and
after the mid-term.
Then we talked about what
strategies meant in this
context, and the basic idea is
strategies are
instructions--strategies for
each player--give them an
instruction at each of their
information sets.
Then we talked about what
sub-games were,
and, leaving aside
technicalities,
sub-games were just games
within games.
And finally we introduced the
idea of sub-game perfection
which is our new solution
concept that refines the idea of
Nash equilibrium.
What sub-game perfection is
going to do is it's going to
instruct the players to play a
Nash equilibrium in every
sub-game.
Another way of saying it is,
a sub-game equilibrium is a
Nash equilibrium in the whole
game, but in each sub-game it
induces Nash play as well.
Now, we're going to see today
examples.
If we have time I'll go through
three different examples,
and I'll tell you at the end of
each example what it is I'm
hoping to be able to take away
from that example.
So, last time was a lot of
formal stuff.
Today is going to be a lot of
examples.
Okay, that's our agenda.
Here's a game.
Here's our first example.
And I call this example,
I call this game,
"don't screw up," for reasons
we'll see in a minute.
So this is a game in which
Player 1 has to choose between
Up and Down.
If Player 1 chooses Up then
Player 2 gets to move and
chooses between left and right.
And if Player 2 chooses left
then Player 1 gets to move again
and Player 1 chooses between up
or down.
Everyone looking at that game?
So why don't we play this game
since we haven't played a game
for a while.
We'll play a couple of games
today.
So what I'm going to do is
let's divide the class in two.
So if I just draw a line down
the middle of the class,
everybody to my left (to your
right), everybody on this side
of the class is a Player 1.
Okay you're all Player 1's.
And everyone on this side of
class you're Player 2,
including you guys hiding from
the camera, you're Player 2's.
Okay, so let's figure out what
we're going to do.
Everyone had the time to look
at the game?
So Player 1's you get to move
first, those of you who are
going to choose Down raise your
hand now.
Raise your hand.
Wave it in the air.
Keep it up so the camera can
see you.
And those of you who are going
to choose Up raise your hands.
Lots more Ups.
Those of you who chose Up why
don't you all stand up.
I don't want to do all the
exercise here,
so all those who chose Up,
stand up.
So you can see that choosing
down ends the game,
so this many people are still
playing the game.
Everyone who is still sitting
down, everyone who sat down here
has exited.
All right, Player 2's you get
to move now.
So Player 2's,
those of you who choose right,
including the people on this
aisle,
those people who choose right
raise your hand now--one right
over there.
Those of you who choose left
raise your hands.
Why don't you guys all stand
up, just to get you awake on a
Monday morning,
everyone's sleepy otherwise.
Let's go back to Player
2's--sorry Player 1--those of
you who are still in the game.
So those of you who chose Up
the first time,
how many of you now choose
down?
Raise your hand if you choose
down;
and raise your hand if you
choose up.
Just to get a sample of this,
let's get the 2's to sit down
again so people can see them.
So 2's sit down.
Those of you Player 1's who are
still in the game who were
choosing up raise your hand now.
I think that's everybody,
is that correct?
Okay, you can all sit down.
So let's just talk about this
game for a while and then we'll
analyze it.
Now, this is not a difficult
game from the point of view of
stuff we've done since the
mid-term.
It's pretty clear what we
should do in this game by
backward induction.
So why don't we start there.
Okay, so by backward induction,
we find that if Player 1 gets
to move a second time then
they're choosing between 4 and
3,
and they're going to choose 4.
Player 2, if they get to move,
knowing that Player 1 is going
to choose up tomorrow,
they're going to be choosing
between 3 if they choose left or
2 if they choose right.
So they're going to stay in the
game and choose left,
which is what most of you did.
Finally, Player 1 at the
beginning of the game,
knows that Player 2 is going to
choose left whereupon she's
going to choose up,
so if she chooses Up she's
going to end up getting 4,
and if she chooses Down she's
going to get 2,
so she's going to choose Up.
So it's clear what backward
induction does in this game and
that's what most people did in
the game.
Is that right?
However, not everybody did it.
Some of the Player 1's
actually, why don't you raise
your hand, those people who
chose Down--the ones who chose
down.
There were more than that.
You can all stand up.
Those of you who didn't stand
up just now raise your hands.
People are hiding now,
but that's okay.
Those people who chose Down,
they may have had a reason for
choosing Down,
and their reason for choosing
Down might have been that they
thought--even though they can do
backward induction--so even
though they know that by
backward induction Up gets them
the better answer--they might be
worried that if they choose Up,
Player 2 will screw up and
choose right.
Notice that if Player 2 chooses
right then Player 1 only gets 1,
whereas Down yielded 2.
So in some sense Down was the
"safe" thing to do for Player 1
given that they might be worried
that Player 2 might screw up.
Does that roughly--just nod if
this is the case:
for those people who chose down
is that kind of what you were
thinking?
Some people are shaking their
heads, but some people are
nodding.
That's a good sign.
Now why might Player 2 in fact
screw up and choose right.
Because Player 2 might,
themselves, think that Player 1
might screw up at this stage.
If Player 1 were to screw up at
the last stage and choose down,
then Player 2 by choosing left
would only get 1,
and for him the safe option
therefore is right which yields
2.
So, to get the backward
induction answer here--which
most of us did--to get the
backward induction answer here
relies on Player 1 trusting
Player 2 to play backward
induction,
and that requires Player 1 to
have trust in Player 2 trusting
Player 1 not to screw up in the
last stage.
So say it again,
Player 1 needs Player 2 not to
screw up, and that means Player
1 needs to trust that Player 2
will trust her not to screw up.
Everyone see the game?
Okay, so let's try and analyze
this game using what we learned
last time and see what we find.
So the first thing to do is
let's look at strategies in this
game.
So Player 2 just has two
strategies, left and right,
because Player 2 only has one
information set--and notice this
game is actually a game of
perfect information so it's
going to be very easy.
Player 1 has two information
sets, this information set and
that information set.
At each of them Player 1 has
two choices so she must have
four strategies in all.
So this game when we put it in
its matrix form is going to be a
4 x 2 game.
Here it is.
And the strategies for Player 1
are (Up, up),
(Up, down), (Down,
up), and (Down,
down).
And the strategies for Player 2
are just left and right.
And now we can put the payoffs
in.
So ((Up, up),
left) gets us (4,3).
((Up, up), right) gets us (1,2).
((Up, down),
left) gets us (3,1).
((Up, up, right) gets us (1,2)
again: we end up exiting the
game here.
(Down, up) is easy because it's
just exiting the game at the
first stage, so all of these are
going to be just (2,1).
Everyone happy with that?
So what I've done is translated
the game into its matrix form.
And let's look for Nash
equilibria in this game.
Let me do it at the board since
it's quite easy at this stage.
So to look for Nash equilibria,
let's just worry about pure
strategy equilibria for now.
So if Player 2 was choosing
left then Player 1's best
response is the (Up,
up) strategy.
And if Player 2 is choosing
right, then Player 1's best
response is either (Down,
up) or (Down,
down).
That's exactly the conversation
we just had.
If Player 2 was going to "screw
up" and choose right then Player
1 wants to get out of the game
immediately.
Conversely, if Player 1 is
choosing (Up,
up) then Player 2 is happy and
is going to choose left,
trusting Player 1.
If Player 1 was going to choose
(Up, down), however,
that's Player 1 screwing up at
the second stage.
So in that case Player 2 wants
to get out of the game and
choose right.
If Player 1 is choosing (Down,
up) then Player 2 is
actually--it doesn't matter
they're indifferent.
And if Player 2 is choosing
(Down, down) then once again
Player 2 is indifferent since
they don't get to move at all.
So from this we see that there
are three Nash equilibria,
let me call them 1,2,
and 3.
So one Nash equilibrium is
((Up, up), left).
Another Nash equilibrium is
((Down, up, right):
that's here.
And the third equilibrium is
((Down, down),
right).
So there are three pure
strategy Nash equilibria in this
game.
Let's just see what they do.
So the first one ((Up,
up), left) is Up,
left, up so it gets us to here.
So this one is the same
equilibrium as corresponds to
backward induction.
Is that right?
This one's the backward
induction equilibrium,
and the other two are
different.
((Down, up),
right) and ((Down,
down), right) both end up down
here exiting the game
immediately,
so both of these other
equilibria fail backward
induction.
So let's put backward induction
with a line through it:
they're failing backward
induction.
So you might ask why are they
equilibria?
We've seen examples like this
before, for example,
in the entry game.
We looked at some examples last
time.
So, in this game,
the reason these are equilibria
even though they fail backward
induction exactly coincides with
that conversation we just had
about worrying about the other
person screwing up.
So, in particular,
if Player 1 thinks that Player
2 is choosing right--that is to
say,
thinks that Player 2 is going
to screw up--then Player 1
doesn't want to travel up the
tree because she knows she'll be
carried down here,
and instead she just chooses
the safe option and gets 2.
So from Player 1's point of
view, if Player 2 was going to
choose right,
then getting out of the game
doing the safe thing is the best
response for Player 1.
And for Player 2's point of
view, if Player 1's exiting the
game it really doesn't matter
what Player 2 says she's going
to do,
because she doesn't get to move
anyway so that's why these are
both equilibria.
Okay, so what we're going to do
next, we've translated this into
a tree.
We've written down the
strategies.
We want to actually see which
of these Nash equilibria are
sub-game perfect?
Let me give myself a bit more
room here because I want to keep
this in sight.
So let's get rid of this and
raise this one.
So the next question is which
of these three Nash equilibria
are sub-game perfect?
To do that we need to start by
identifying the sub-games.
And, of course,
just having hoisted that board
up there, I have to hoist it
down again.
Okay, so what are the sub-games
here?
Well the simplest sub-game is
this simple sub-game at the end,
in which Player 1 moves.
That's a very obvious sub-game,
is that right?
That's a little game within a
game, it's a rather trivial game
because it's a one player game,
but it is a game.
So let's examine that one
first, that's the last sub-game.
So the last sub-game here is a
somewhat trivial sub-game.
It looks like this.
Player 1 is the only mover and
they're choosing either up or
down and the payoffs are (4,3)
and (3,1): and frankly we don't
really care at this point what
Player 2's payoffs are because
Player 1 is the only person
who's playing in this sub-game.
But nevertheless,
let's put them there.
And if we write this up as a
matrix--here it is as a matrix.
Since Player 1 is the only
mover they're choosing between
up and down, and the payoffs are
(4,3) and (3,1),
and of course Player 2 doesn't
get to move so Player 2 is
irrelevant here.
And clearly the only Nash
equilibria in this game is for
Player 1 to choose up.
Player 2, it doesn't really
matter what they choose,
there's nothing they can do
about it anyway,
but for Player 1 to choose up
is the Nash equilibria.
So the Nash equilibria in this
trivial sub-game is 1 just
chooses up.
Is that right?
So let's look at the play
induced by our three candidate
Nash equilibria in this
sub-game.
So each of our candidate Nash
equilibria--here they are,
this one, this one,
and this one--have an
instruction of how Player 1
should play in this sub-game.
And let me just pause a second.
The reason that these three
equilibria have an instruction
for how Player 1 should play in
the sub-game is because of our
definition of a strategy.
Each strategy tells the player
how they should move at every
information set of that player.
So even if the strategy is such
that that information set won't
be reached, the strategy still
has to tell you what you would
do when you got there.
And now for the first time
perhaps we're going to see why
that redundancy helps us.
So let's look at the
instructions.
Each of them gives an
instruction.
The first one tells us to play
up in this sub-game.
The second one says up again,
and notice this was redundant.
Once you've chosen Down you
know you're not going to get to
make a choice at the third node,
or your second node,
but nevertheless there's the
instruction and it says up.
The third one says down.
So this is the instructions of
these three equilibria in this
little sub-game.
This is the play prescribed by
these three equilibria in this
sub-game.
Two of them say up and those
ones are going to induce the
Nash equilibrium in this
sub-game, but the third one does
not.
The third one says down and
that's not allowed.
That's not allowed in a
sub-game perfect equilibrium
because a sub-game perfect
equilibrium has to prescribe
play in every sub-game that's
Nash,
and here the third equilibrium
is telling Player 1 to choose
down which is not a Nash
equilibrium in the sub-game.
So what are we doing here?
Let's make it clear.
We're finding the sub-game
perfect equilibria.
And what we've done is:
number 3 is eliminated because
it induces play in this sub-game
that is not Nash equilibrium,
not a Nash equilibrium in the
sub-game.
We're really putting stuff
together now:
to be able to draw this
conclusion,
we really used the fact that
strategy 3 contained a redundant
instruction, an instruction down
at this node that was never
reached.
But that helped us get rid of
it.
So that one's gone: 3 is gone.
Let's proceed.
I'm going to run out of board
space here.
Have people got this one down?
I'll bring it back in a second,
almost, let me give it a
second.
What I want to do now is look
at the next sub-game.
Maybe what I can do if I just
remove this comment,
I can work on the right hand
board, that'll allow you to look
at it.
So all that comment said was 3
is eliminated.
Let me work now on the right
hand half of this board,
that'll allow it to be up there
a bit longer.
Okay, so let's now look at the
next sub-game,
and again, we're going to work
from the back.
So the next sub-game back is
the sub-game that starts from
this node, the sub-game that
starts from that node.
So let's identify that in a
different color.
I used blue so let me use pink.
So now we're going to look at
this sub-game,
this big pink sub-game,
and again in this pink sub-game
this game looks like this.
It starts with Player 2
choosing between left and right,
and then Player 1 has to choose
up or down, and the payoffs are
(1,2), (4,3) and (3,1).
Once again let's look at the
matrix form of this sub-game,
and this is a little bit less
trivial than the last one
because now there are really two
players playing.
So here's the matrix that goes
along with this.
Player 1 is choosing between up
or down and Player 2 is choosing
between left or right.
And this is slightly,
slightly cheating because in
fact, Player 1 of course knows
what Player 2 is going to have
done by the time she moves,
but never mind it'll do for now.
Let's just put the payoffs in.
So (up, left) is (4,3) and
(down, left) is (3,1) and (up,
right) is (1,2) and this must
also be (1,2).
Everyone happy with that?
Just putting the payoffs in.
And let's just look again at
pure-strategy Nash equilibria
here.
There are actually mixed ones,
but let's just worry about pure
ones for now.
So the pure Nash equilibria
here in this little sub-game are
what?
Well, let's just see.
If 2 chose left then 1 wants to
choose up.
If 2 chooses right it doesn't
really matter what 1 chooses
because she isn't going to get
to move anyway.
Conversely, if 1 chooses up
then 2 wants to choose left.
That's the example of 1 not
screwing up, so 2 wants to stay
in the game.
But if 1 was to choose down
then Player 2 would like to get
out of the game,
so if Player 2 thinks 1 is
going to screw up she wants to
exit the game.
Very quickly we can see there
are two equilibria here.
One of them is (up,
left) and the other one is
(down, right).
They correspond to playing down
this way, that's (down,
right) and (up,
left) playing up this way.
Once again, let's look at our
three equilibria in the parent
game.
Here's our three equilibria in
the parent game,
and let's see what play they
induced in this little sub-game.
So we'll do exactly what we did
before.
So 1,2, and 3:
these are our three equilibria
from above.
And equilibrium number 1,
((Up, up), left) in this game
prescribes (up,
left).
Is that right?
Equilibrium number 2,
((Down, up),
right) here prescribes up,
right.
And equilibrium number 3,
((Down, down),
right) here prescribes (down,
right).
So which of these are
prescribing Nash equilibria in
the sub-game?
Well (up, left) is an
equilibrium.
It's that one.
(up, left) is an equilibrium so
this is okay.
And (down, right) was an
equilibrium, so 3 is okay in
this sub-game.
But (up, right) is not a Nash
equilibrium.
So in this sub-game,
Nash equilibrium number 2,
the ((Down, up),
right) equilibrium is
prescribing play that is not a
Nash equilibrium in the
sub-game: so it's eliminated.
It can't be a sub-game perfect
equilibrium.
So here 2 is eliminated since
it induces non-Nash equilibrium
play in this sub-game.
Now we're done,
we know about the whole thing.
So what we did here we started
with the whole game,
we found there were three Nash
equilibria,
we found that only one of them
agreed with backward induction.
We then looked at the sub-games.
We first of all looked at that
blue sub-game and we found that
one of the equilibria,
equilibrium number 3,
was eliminated.
Equilibrium number 3 is not
prescribing Nash behavior in
this sub-game.
Then we looked at the slightly
more complicated sub-game,
the pink sub-game,
and we found that equilibrium
number 2 prescribes the behavior
(up, right) which is not Nash in
this sub-game.
At this stage we've eliminated
two of the three equilibria and
we're just left with one.
And the one we're left with,
the only sub-game perfect
equilibrium, the only
equilibrium that wasn't
eliminated by the fact that it
would prescribe bad behavior in
sub-games,
the only SPE is number 1:
which is (Up,
up) and left.
What do we notice?
We notice that that's the
equilibrium, that's the play
that backward induction would
have selected.
So notice this is the backward
induction prediction.
So what are the lessons here?
The lessons here are that our
new idea, the idea of sub-game
perfect equilibrium is pretty
easy to go about finding.
You just look at sub-games and
check that the play in each
sub-game has to be Nash play.
If you start at the back,
you construct it by rolling
backwards, much like we did
backward induction.
Start at the last sub-game and
work backwards.
The second thing is--not
surprisingly given that
remark--not surprisingly,
where backward induction
applies,
for example in this game,
the sub-game perfect
equilibrium will find the
equilibrium that is consistent
with backward induction.
Remember that was our aim last
week.
We wanted a way of refining
Nash equilibrium to throw away
those Nash equilibria that were
inconsistent with backward
induction.
So sub-game perfect equilibrium
has done that.
It tells us now if backward
induction applies,
the Nash equilibria you should
focus on are the sub-game
perfect equilibria.
Indeed, most people in the
class played that equilibrium
just now.
Okay so that was really what I
wanted to say about this
example, but let me just make a
remark in passing.
I made this remark in the
middle, so let me just make it
again.
When we write down strategies,
those strategies tell us what
seem to redundant moves.
But being forced to write down
those redundant moves is useful
because it allows us to model
what other people think you
would have done at those later
nodes.
And sometimes I have to think
what you think I would have done
at this later node before I
decide not to go down that
branch of the tree.
So being able to write down
everything in a strategy allows
us to have everything in front
of us and makes that analysis
simple;
and that's exactly what we did
here.
So this was a fairly mundane
example, because in particular
we didn't use any kind of
information set.
So next let's look at an
example that does use some
information sets.
So: new example.
Let me clean this off.
Once again, I want to play this
example.
But what I'd really like to
do--we're going to call this
game the matchmaker game--and
what I'd actually like to find
out is: do we still have our
couple we tried to send on a
date?
Our hapless couple we tried to
send on a date at about week
three.
Are you guys still here?
There's the guy,
what's your name again?
Student: David.
Professor Ben Polak:
David, and what was the--is
she hiding?
There she is thank you.
Your name was?
Student: Nina.
Professor Ben Polak:
Nina and David.
Good, can we get some mikes to
Nina and David actually?
Let me do it.
I'll go on talking while I'm
doing this–.
Where's David,
and Ale can you get a mike to
Nina?
That would be great thank you.
All right, so for weeks we've
been trying to get this couple
to go on a date.
It's our attempt to get
economics majors to become real
people.
It's a hard thing to do and
they're kind of the hapless
couple because first we sent
them to the movies and they end
up going to different movies;
and then we sent them off for a
romantic weekend in New England
and they end up doing different
things,
one went to the theatre and
another one apple picking,
I forget which way around it
was.
And at this point,
I figure I'm a pretty bad
matchmaker so what I'm going to
do is.
I'm going to introduce a third
player into the game as the
matchmaker.
So first of all I'll write down
what the game is.
So the game at this point--the
game is going to look like this.
Player 1 is the matchmaker,
we can call him Player M if you
like, and he has a choice,
he or she has a choice.
She could not send the couple
out on a date or she could send
the couple out on a date.
But being a better matchmaker
than me, if she sends them out
on a date, she's going to stake
some money, she'll pay for the
date.
And in the date once again
they're trying to meet,
and once again,
unfortunately,
they haven't figured out where
to meet.
We'll put the payoffs in,
in a second and we'll tell you
what the strategies are.
So what I'm going to assume
here is I'm going to let Jake
our T.A.
be our matchmaker.
And the reason I'm choosing
Jake is I think he's the nearest
thing I have in mind in this
class to being a Jewish mother.
I mean: he's neither Jewish--I
think he's not Jewish and he's
not my mother,
but he is the T.A.,
who's responsible for bringing
some drink everyday in case I
pass out in the lecture.
So that's the nearest thing I
can think of.
So Jake's going to be our
Jewish mother,
and Jake's going to either send
these guys on a date or not.
And Jake's smarter than me at
this: he's actually good at
matchmaking.
And what he's going to do is,
he's going to send them
somewhere where they really--he
knows Yale students better than
I do--and he's going to send
them really somewhere where
they're going to meet.
So he's going to send them to
go to the same lecture class
next year, and then they'll be
sitting in the aisles in this
huge lecture class and they're
bound to meet.
All of you have sat next to
other people at some point.
So that seems like a good idea.
So the classes he thinks of
sending them to--he says go to a
large lecture class.
So they're either going to go
to the Gaddis class which is
called "Cold War";
or to the Spence class which is
called "China."
Everyone know a little bit
about these classes?
These seem like reasonable
classes to go to meet your--to
have a date--to meet somebody.
I mean the Cold War can be a
fun class, I mean,
you hope it isn't a prediction
of the future relationship but
the Cold War seems all right.
And China is,
by all accounts,
a fantastic class.
It involves,
something involving 20 million
people, most of them were in the
class together,
so it's a pretty big class.
So let's do that.
Unfortunately Jake makes the
same mistake I do,
he's not going to tell them
which class to go to.
So they have to decide whether
to take Gaddis or Spence,
and once again they're
coordinating.
We'll call them Players 2 and 3.
So here they are trying to
coordinate, and the payoffs are
as follows.
So let's put in Jake's payoffs
first of all.
So if they manage to
coordinate, first of all,
if Jake doesn't send them,
everybody gets nothing.
And if Jake does send them and
they coordinate Jake makes 1
because he feels really happy
about this.
After all there must be some
motivation for people
matchmaking.
So if they coordinate down here
Jake gets 1 as well,
but if they fail to coordinate,
Jake feels rotten about it,
particularly because he paid
for them to go this
class--whatever the cost of a
class at Yale is--which is
probably quite a lot actually.
So okay we'll call it 1 though
and otherwise the payoffs are
exactly the same as the payoffs
we used when we looked at this
game earlier on in the course.
So the payoffs are going to be
(2,1) here and (0,0) if they
fail to coordinate;
and (0,0) here if they fail to
coordinate;
and (1,2), (1,2) here.
So the implication of this is
that Player 2 who we'll assume
is David, so David would like to
meet Nina but all other things
being equal,
he'd like to meet her at the
Cold War.
And Nina would like to meet
David, but all things being
equal, she would like to meet in
China.
Not literally in China,
but in the class.
So this is our game and we're
going to analyze this game,
but before we analyze it let's
try and play it.
So what we need to do is first
of all let's make sure things
work smoothly,
let's have David write down
which class he's going to
choose,
and Nina write down which class
she's going to choose.
I've lost sight of Nina.
Somebody has to point
out--there she is.
Write down which class you are
going to choose.
Something been written down?
Jake you got your mikethere,
so Jake are you going to send
this hapless couple or not?
Student: So I have Dave
in my section actually and I
hear how much he's been talking
about Nina, so I'm going to roll
the dice and send them.
Professor Ben Polak:
He's going to send them
good, so we have them going off
to this class and now let's see
what they wrote down.
So Dave what did you write down?
Student: I'm going to
give in and go to China.
Professor Ben Polak:
You're going to go to China
and Nina?
Student: I chose S.
Professor Ben Polak:
Great, so they managed to
meet, so it's a successful date.
So let's give them a round of
applause.
I hear it's a great class too.
And in fact,
I don't think it's going to
happen forever because I think
he must be approaching
retirement.
So that seems a pretty good
choice.
So good: that worked very well.
Let's have a look now at this.
Let's analyze this game and see
what we can do with this game.
So how are we going to analyze
this game?
So no surprise we're going to
use the idea of a sub-game
perfect equilibrium,
I'll collect the mikes later
don't worry.
So we're going to use the idea
of a sub-game perfect
equilibrium.
So how do we figure out how to
work out what a sub-game perfect
equilibrium is?
We're going to use the same
basic idea that we used--what
we've been using all along in
backward induction.
It's the same idea in the game
we just looked at just now.
What we're going to do is,
rather than start from the last
decision node (we can't do that
anymore) and work backwards,
instead of doing that,
we're going to start from the
last sub-game and work
backwards.
In this example it's pretty
obvious what the last sub-game
is.
The last sub-game,
the game within a game--there
is only really one--the game
within the game is this object
here, is that right?
This is the game within the
game.
Now, I could at this stage,
I could do something else.
I could write down the whole
matrix for the whole game and
have Jake choose the matrix,
and Dave and Nina choose the
row and the column,
but that's going to get us
astray.
So I mean we could do that but
let's not worry about that.
Let's just start doing things
backwards.
So when we do things backwards
we'll start at the last sub-game
and that last sub-game is an old
friend of ours,
it looks exactly like this.
Let's just write it in.
So it involves Players 2 and 3.
And 2 was choosing between
Gaddis and Spence.
And 3 was choosing between
And their payoffs were--let me
leave a space here--so it was
(2,1), (1,2),
(0,0), (0,0).
So here are the payoffs of the
relevant players in the game but
while we're here why don't we
put in Jake's payoffs as well.
So Jake's payoffs were 1 here,
1 here, -1 here,
and -1 there.
So the only relevant players
here are Players 2 and 3,
but I've put Player 1's payoffs
in as well because:
why not, why not just keep
track of it.
Everyone happy that that
exactly describes this little
game?
For all intents and purposes we
can forget the first payoff but
there it is.
This is a game we've seen many
times so far.
It's the battle of the sexes,
or the battle of Dave and Nina,
and in this game we already
know what the equilibria are.
So the equilibria here,
let me just underline the best
responses.
So if Nina is choosing Gaddis
then Dave chooses Gaddis.
If Nina is choosing Spence then
Dave would like to choose Spence
and conversely.
So I've just underlined the
best responses for the players
who are actually involved in the
game and haven't bothered
underlining anything for Jake
because he isn't a player in
this game.
Does that make sense?
So the pure Nash equilibria in
this game are essentially
(Gaddis, Gaddis) or (Spence,
Spence).
That's pretty easy.
From Jake's point of view,
each of these pure strategy
Nash equilibria yield a payoff
for him of what?
What does he get?
If they go to (Gaddis,
Gaddis), he's happy that they
met and he gets 1 and if they
choose (Spence,
Spence), he's happy that they
met and he gets 1.
Jake himself doesn't really
mind whether Dave and Nina learn
about China or learn about the
Cold War.
He just wants them to meet.
So, both of these yield 1 for
Jake.
They both yield a value of 1
for Player 1,
who is Jake.
So from Jake's point of view,
going back a stage--what we're
going to do now,
just as we did with backward
induction, we're going to roll
the game back.
So we started by analyzing this
sub-game and now we're going to
roll it back a stage,
just as we did with backward
induction.
So when we roll back Jake is
moving here, if Jake chooses not
to send them then we get (0,0,
0) but the key part of this is
the first 0, that's Jake's
payoff.
And if Jake sends them,
then what Jake gets is the
value to Jake--I'll put in Jake
but value to Player 1--okay
value to Jake of the Nash
equilibria in this sub-game.
Not a big thing to write,
but that's what Jake gets.
And the others do too:
the others get that as well.
In this case,
rather than writing that long
piece, this is just equal to 1.
Is that right?
So if Jake sends them he knows
that they're going to play a
Nash equilibrium in this
sub-game,
or he believes they're going to
play a Nash equilibrium in this
sub-game.
And either of those two Nash
equilibria in the sub-game yield
a payoff to Jake of 1.
So actually,
one of them is 1,
one of them yields payoffs of
(1,1,2);
and the other yields payoffs of
(1,2,1).
But since Jake is the only
mover here, let's just focus on
Jake.
So from Jake's point of view
he's really choosing between 0
and 1, so he's going to choose
send.
So the sub-game perfect
equilibrium therefore--there are
actually two of them here--one
is (send, Spence,
Spence), that's what actually
happened.
But there's another one which
is (send, Gaddis,
Gaddis) that would also have
been a pure strategy sub-game
perfect equilibrium.
So in either case,
what we did,
just to remind ourselves,
we first of all solved the
equilibrium down the sub-game,
the equilibrium in this blue
sub-game.
We figured how much that
equilibrium was worth for
everybody--but in particular for
Jake,
but for everybody--and then we
rolled that payoff back and
looked at Jake's choice.
In this particular case that
game has two equilibria,
(send, Spence,
Spence) and (send,
Gaddis, Gaddis).
However, some of you must be
suspecting at this point that
there's actually another
sub-game perfect equilibrium
here.
How do we know that?
Well let's just think about
this game.
We've been trying to send this
couple on a date all semester.
They haven't gone on a date all
semester.
I'm embarrassing them,
but they haven't gone on a date
all semester.
So there must be some
possibility that they would fail
to coordinate.
It would be a pretty weird
notion of equilibrium that
concluded that they always
manage to coordinate and hence
Jake always wants to send them.
Is that right?
So let's also look at the other
equilibria here.
Now the reason there's another
equilibrium in this
sub-game--sorry,
the reason there's another
equilibrium in the whole
game--the reason there's another
sub-game perfect equilibrium in
the whole game is that there's
another Nash equilibrium in the
sub-game.
What's the other Nash
equilibrium in the sub-game?
They could mix.
So it turns out that in the
sub-game (here it is) there's
also a third mixed equilibrium.
There is a mixed Nash
equilibrium.
Now we know how to work that
out.
We could write down a P and a
Q, and we could look for those
indifference conditions and
solve it out.
But this is a sub-game,
sorry this is a game,
this sub-game corresponds to a
game we've seen many times in
this class so far,
and I think we probably
remember what that equilibrium
is.
Is that right?
I do anyway,
so let's see if you remember it
as well.
I'll write it down and we'll
see if you all looked alarmed.
So I claim the equilibrium,
the other equilibrium has Dave
playing with probability
(2/3,1/3), and has Nina playing
with probability (1/3,2/3).
So this is another equilibrium
in the sub-game.
People remember that this was
an equilibrium in battle of the
sexes?
Yeah, people are nodding at me,
yeah okay.
So it isn't too unintuitive.
We all know how we'd work it
out.
We could go back and put in the
P and the Q, but it isn't too
unintuitive, it has Dave going
more often to the lecture course
that he would prefer all other
things being equal;
and it has Nina going more
often to the lecture course that
she would prefer all other
things being equal.
And they do so in just such a
way as to make each of them
indifferent.
Now, this sub-game induces a
different value for Jake.
So suppose Jake thinks:
"I trust Dave and Nina to play
a Nash equilibrium in their
sub-game but I don't know which
one it is and I think maybe
they're going to play this one."
So suppose Jake thinks that
this is the equilibrium that
Dave and Nina are going to play.
So now should Jake send them or
not?
Well let's work it out.
So now if he sends them,
if Jake sends Dave and Nina,
or more anonymously if Player 1
sends Players 2 and 3,
then with what probability will
they meet?
Well this is just a little math
exercise, let's have a look at
the game again.
So Dave is playing 2/3,1/3,
is that right?
Nina is playing 2/3,1/3,
So the probability of their
meeting is the probability of
this box, they could meet at
Gaddis,
plus the probability of this
box, they could meet at Spence,
is that right?
So the probability of this box
is 1/3 x 2/3 so this box has
probability 2/9 and the
probability of this box is 2/3 x
1/3 so this box has probability
2/9.
So the probability of their
meeting is 2/9 + 2/9 that makes
4/9.
Everyone okay with that?
So if Jake sends Dave and Nina
and they play this mixed
strategy equilibrium,
then they meet with probability
2/9 + 2/9,2/9 at Gaddis,
2/9 at Spence for a total of
4/9,
which means they failed to meet
with probability--well if
they're meeting with probability
of 4/9 what must be the
probability that they're failing
to meet?
5/9, thank you.
So they fail to meet with
probability of 5/9.
So Jake's expected payoff if he
sends them, the value for Jake
of this equilibrium is what?
So the value to Jake of this
Nash equilibrium,
if he sends them,
is 4/9 x 1 + 5/9 x -1 for a
total of -1/9.
Everyone okay with that?
So if Jake sends them they fail
to meet 5/9 of the time and he
gets -1 each of those times.
They succeed in meeting 4/9 of
the time, he gets +1 each of
those times, so his expected
payoff,
his expected value from sending
Dave and Nina on the date is
-1/9.
So from Jake's point of view,
what this game looks like,
if he thinks that this is the
Nash equilibrium being played:
if he doesn't send he gets 0
and if he does,
he gets the value of this Nash
equilibrium, which in this case
is -1/9.
So he's not going to send and
the SPE here is (not send,
"mix," "mix") where this is the
mix.
So there's a third equilibrium
here in which our matchmaker
says this hapless couple is just
too hapless: they're going to
play the mixed strategy
equilibrium in which case it
isn't worth my while sending
them on the date.
You guys were lucky because
Jake chose the other
equilibrium.
He figured you were playing the
other equilibrium,
which it turned out that you
were.
So in this game there were
three sub-game perfect
equilibria, one for each of the
Nash equilibria in the sub-game,
as it turned out.
There was one in which Jake
sent them and they coordinated
on the pure strategy equilibrium
in the game (S,S).
There was one in which Jake
sent them and they coordinated
on the pure strategy equilibrium
in the sub-game (G,G).
And there's one in which Jake
didn't send them,
but had he had in fact sent
them,
they would have both mixed,
and hence, for a lot of the
time, failed to coordinate.
Now, what's the big lesson here?
The big lesson of the first
game we saw this morning was
that sub-game perfect
equilibrium implies backward
induction.
The big lesson of this
game--other than the fact that
we're getting closer to getting
Dave and Nina on their date--the
big lesson of this game is to
show that to find sub-game
perfect equilibria,
all you have to do is keep your
head and solve out the Nash
equilibria in each of the
sub-games,
roll the payoffs back up,
and then look for behavior up
the tree.
Once again, you look for the
Nash equilibria in each of these
sub-games, roll the payoffs back
up,
and then see what the optimal
moves are higher up the tree.
So we have time to do one more
example, and the third example I
want to do is more of an
application.
So far we've seen some fairly
simple examples.
Now I want to do an application.
The application I want to do is
kind of a classic business
school case if you like,
or a mini case involving
strategic investment.
The game is this,
or the setting is this.
There are two firms,
we'll call them A and B.
And these two firms,
initially, before we start
considering what we're actually
going to talk about,
initially they are playing
Cournot competition.
So two firms and they're
playing Cournot competition.
And we can imagine that they're
producing fertilizer.
And let's be specific here,
let's assume that the prices in
this market are given by the
following demand curve 2 - 1/3 x
[qA + qB],
so this is the demand curve
that they face.
We'll assume that costs,
marginal costs,
c is equal to $1 a ton.
So this is the price in dollars
per ton, and the costs are $1
per ton.
In a minute what we're going to
do is we're going to consider a
change in this game,
but before we do that let's
just remind ourselves what the
Cournot equilibrium of this game
would look like.
Let's do a bit of a review.
So it's been a while since
we've seen Cournot,
so let's remind ourselves.
So I claim that the quantity,
the Cournot quantity chosen Q*
has the formula [a--c]/ 3b.
Is that right?
If you go back in your notes
you'll find it.
I'm not going to re-solve it
here.
We've done it many times.
So [a--c]/3b trust me,
is what came out of our
calculation before the mid-term.
What I want to do is,
I just want to make sure we can
translate that into numbers
here.
Sorry for having it in letters,
but let's translate it into
numbers.
So in particular,
this a is this 2,
is that right?
This c is this 1 and this b is
this 1/3, is that right?
So let's just put that down.
So in this case this is
[2--1]/[3 x 1/3],
so this says that this is a
million tons.
So the quantity here,
the Cournot quantity is a
million tons each.
So: one each.
So in this equilibrium,
each of these two firms is
producing a million tons of
fertilizer.
What else do we know?
We know therefore what prices
must be.
Let's just do that before we
even get started.
So prices must be [2 - 1/3]
times the quantity that the
first firm produces plus the
quantity that the second firm
produces.
So that's 2 - 2/3 so that
should be 4/3,
if I've got that right,
or one and a third.
So prices here are $1.33 per
ton.
Finally profits.
So profit for each firm here,
in this equilibrium,
before we even start the game,
or start the more interesting
part of the game,
profit is what?
So they're going to get $1 and
1/3 for every ton they produce.
It's going to cost them $1 to
produce each ton and they're
producing one million of these
things.
So their profits are 1/3,
if these are millions,
their profits are 1/3 of $1
million dollars.
So this is their per period
profit, in each period they're
doing this, each year they're
doing this and this is their
profits in each period.
So this is a simple model that
we've done many times before.
This is Cournot,
and now we're going to make it
more interesting.
If the algebra here was a bit
quick don't worry about it,
check it at home,
it's just basic,
basic algebra.
So now suppose that you are the
manager of Firm A.
So it's a classic business
school case.
I'm looking at my
business-school students in the
balcony.
You're the manager of Firm A
and you have to choose whether
to accept an offer to rent a new
machine.
So this new machine has two
features.
The first--well three
features--the first feature is
it only works for A.
So this machine is being
offered to you.
It wouldn't fit in to Firm B's
technology, so this is only
being offered for A.
The second feature of this
machine is it costs $0.7 million
dollars in rental.
So each year you rent this
machine, you'd have to pay $0.7
million dollars.
But that's the bad news.
The good news is it will lower
A's costs to $0.50 a ton.
So classic business-school
situation.
You're the manager of a firm.
You're involved in competition
with another firm,
B.
And suddenly an opportunity
comes along to rent some new
technology.
It's going to cost you $0.7 a
year to rent this machine,
but it will lower your costs by
$.50 a ton.
So this is a classic thing that
you might be asked in your
interview for Morgan Stanley
next week.
How many of you are
interviewing with investment
banks?
No one's going to admit it.
In a couple of years,
when you're interviewing with
these guys.
So what's the obvious question?
The obvious question is,
should you go ahead and rent
this new technology or not?
Should you rent it or not?
To rent or not to rent?
Less dramatic than it's
equivalent question in the
English class,
but important nevertheless.
This board is stuck
unfortunately,
so I'll have to write there a
bit more.
So what I want to do is I want
to analyze this three times and
each time I analyze it,
I want us to see what I'm
doing--what mistakes I'm
making--because I want you guys,
when you interview with Morgan
Stanley about this kind of
thing, to impress them so that
they tell lots of people to come
to Yale and preferably give lots
of money to Yale.
So we're going to look at this
way three different times.
And the first thing we're going
to do, the first way we're going
to look at this is look at it as
if we were accountants.
We're going to look at the
accountants' answer to this
question, and some of you may
decide you don't want to
interview with Morgan Stanley or
McKinsey,
you might want to interview
with some accounting firm when
you leave Yale.
God forbid, but you might.
So let's have a look at how the
accountants would answer this
question.
So I think the accountants
would do this.
They would say--but before we
do this let's have a poll.
How many people think you
should rent?
You've had some time to think
about it now.
So how many people think you
should rent the new machine?
How many people think you
should not rent the new machine?
You're not allowed abstensions
here.
Let's try it again:
no abstentions right.
You can't abstain in an
interview.
So you're on the spot,
you're in the boardroom,
how many think you should rent
the new machine?
Raise your hands.
Wave them in the air.
How many people think you
should not rent the new machine?
So we're split kind of down the
middle, I'm looking at my MBA
students to see which they
voted.
Which did you guys vote,
rent or not rent?
Rent, the MBA's seem to think
rent.
We'll see if that's right.
So let's move forward,
so accountant's answer.
So I think what the
accountant's going to say is
this.
They're going to say,
right now you're producing a
million tons a year.
The new machine saves you--so,
let's put per annum--let's try
and be fancy--so a million tons
per annum.
The new machine saves you $.50
per ton.
So if you rent this new
machine, you're producing a
million tons a year,
it's going to save you $.50 a
ton.
So it's going to save you half
of one million a year in
variable cost.
Those people who were in 115 or
150 will know what I mean by
variable cost.
It's the cost you're going to
save in the actual production of
your fertilizer.
So it saves you half a million
a year.
Unfortunately,
it costs you the cost of the
machine, which is a fixed cost
of $0.7 million a year.
And .7 is bigger than .5,
so you should not rent.
So .5 is less than .7 so don't
rent the machine.
How many of you said no?
That's kind of the back of the
envelope calculation you were
doing, is that right?
Kind of the back of the
envelope calculation that
accountants do.
So what's going on here?
Our business school student up
in the balcony says you should
rent.
He took accounting.
I know he did that because you
have to take accounting at
business school.
So what's wrong?
Did he fail accounting,
or is this answer wrong?
The answer is wrong.
There's two things you need to
know about accountants.
One is that they're usually
boring, and the other is that
they're often wrong.
They're more often boring than
wrong, but they're almost always
boring.
So this answer is kind of
boring, and it happens also to
be wrong.
Why is it wrong?
It's wrong because we made an
assumption here that's not a
good assumption.
We made the assumption that
you're going to go on producing
the same amount per year after
you've invested in the new
machine that lowers marginal
costs as you are producing
beforehand.
We made the assumption that it
would lower--we know it lowers
your costs--and we assumed
implicitly that you would go on
producing a million tons a year,
but that's not right.
So let's try and have a more
sophisticated answer,
and if you want to be more
sophisticated and less boring
than accounting,
what class would you want to
take?
Economics probably right,
so let's have a look at an
Economics answer.
Let's look at an Economics 115
answer.
How many of you have taken
Economics 115?
How many of you are in 115 at
the moment?
Quite a few,
okay so let's have a look at
the Economics answer.
Let's see why that previous
answer was wrong.
So here is qA and here is cost
of a $1, your new cost will be
$.50.
So I'm putting prices and costs
on this axis.
And here is your residual
demand curve.
This is the demand curve you
face after the other guy has
finished producing,
so this is your residual demand
curve.
It's the demand curve on that
part of the market you're
supplying, or not being supplied
by the other side of the market.
And to figure out your optimal
quantity on your residual demand
curve what you should do.
It's like you're a monopolist
on this residual demand curve,
so you should set what?
If the answer isn't backward
induction it's probably marginal
revenue equals marginal cost
right?
So let's try that.
So here's the marginal revenue
curve roughly speaking,
should be twice as steep.
This is residual marginal
revenue and here's what you used
to produce.
So we know what this is:
this was a million tons.
This was marginal revenue
hitting marginal cost.
Now your costs have gone down
so notice that your quantity,
your new quantity has gone up.
Your new quantity has gone up
because you slid down the
marginal revenue curve as the
marginal cost curve dropped.
Is that clear to everybody?
So this is the kind of picture
that you probably saw a lot of
in 115, is that right?
Or in 150 for that matter,
is that correct?
So notice in this picture we
can actually see the
accountant's answer,
the boring answer.
The boring answer is this
rectangle.
This rectangle,
this is the accounting answer.
This rectangle is 0.5 x 1,
so it comes out as a 1/2 and
that was the accountant's
answer.
And what did they miss.
What did the accountant's miss?
They missed the triangle.
So I told you they were boring,
they were a little bit square,
so they tend to miss triangles.
So here's the triangle that
they missed.
So we missed this triangle.
And how big is this triangle?
Well we could do it at home,
it's 1/2 base x height.
So we could figure this out.
We know the slope of this line.
We know the slope of this line
is 1/3.
is 2/3.
We know that the height of this
triangle is 1/2.
We could figure out what the
width is as well,
therefore we could do half base
times height.
Turns out that this has area--I
did this at home so let me just
write it down--it has area 3/16.
So again, everyone could figure
out the area of a triangle at
home, is that right?
You all know that from your
probably junior high school
geometry.
So assuming I did it correctly
at home, this is 3/16 which is
approximately 0.19.
So we missed this 0.19.
So how are we doing now?
So we know from the accounting
answer we had a 1/2 in savings.
We know from the Economics
answer that we should add
another 0.19 to this--that's the
triangle--for a total of 0.69
but unfortunately this is still
less than .7 which is the cost
of the machine,
the per annum cost of the
machine.
So it looks like we should
still not rent.
So even after taking Economics
115, which is a good thing to
do--it is much less boring than
accounting and will get you the
accounting answer anyway if you
do things carefully--we still
end up concluding you shouldn't
rent.
But our guy from the business
school said you should rent,
right?
So did he fail Economics as
well as accounting,
or is this answer wrong?
This answer is still wrong.
[I didn't really want to delete
that.
That's a shame.
Oh well, I've done it now.
People've got those numbers
somewhere.
I hope they are in my notes.]
This answer is still wrong.
We need to get the right answer.
So what we need is a third
answer which is the Game Theory
answer, which is also known as
the right answer.
What are we missing?
What's wrong with the Economics
answer?
Somebody?
Everyone knew it was wrong,
why is it wrong?
It looked pretty good,
what's wrong with it?
Let's bounce down here.
Somebody in the front row will
help me.
What did I do wrong?
Student: Firm B also
changes its quantity.
Professor Ben Polak:
Right, in the accounting
answer, we assumed that Firm A
kept its quantity fixed,
that we kept our quantity
fixed, and that was wrong.
But in addition,
Firm B is going to change its
quantity, isn't it?
quantity.
Let's remind ourselves why.
We're still playing Cournot
competition, here's our Cournot
diagram with qA and qB.
So prior to making this
investment the model is
symmetric.
Here it is.
And this is the old best
response of Firm A,
and this is the best response
of Firm B.
What we learned just now in the
Economics answer is what?
We learned that Firm A,
as its costs go down,
will produce more for each
possible quantity that Firm B
produces.
So regardless of what generated
this residual demand curve as
the costs go down for Firm A,
it increases its quantity.
So we know that.
So what's that telling us?
It's telling us that the new
best response of Firm A is
shifted to the right.
This is the new best response
for Firm A.
It's shifted to the right.
It now produces more for any
given quantity that Firm B
produces.
So qA has gone up.
That was our Economics answer.
But that leads Firm B to do
what?
To produce less.
That leads to qB producing less.
Notice we slid down Firm B's
best response line from the old
equilibrium to the new
equilibrium,
and at the new equilibrium Firm
B's production has gone down.
By the way, what kind of game
is it where as Firm A increases
its strategy,
Firm B decreases its strategy
in response?
Strategic substitutes,
right.
So because this is a game of
strategic substitutes--good
interview word,
good word to mention in an
interview--because this is a
game of strategic substitutes,
we know that Firm B reduces its
quantity.
As Firm B reduces its quantity
is that good for A or bad for A?
It's good for A, right?
This is good for Firm A,
it softens competition.
As a consequence,
it leads to an increase in
profit.
Again--we don't have time
today--but what we could do is
we could go back and we could
recalculate the new Cournot
equilibrium.
We could calculate this--we
could as a homework exercise try
it--calculate the new Nash
equilibrium and notice this is a
Nash equilibrium in a sub-game.
Why is this a sub-game?
Because Firm A made its
decision whether to buy this new
machine or not,
and then they played Cournot.
So the Cournot game,
the game up here,
what is this?
This is the sub-game.
This is the diagram of the
sub-game, if you like.
It's the best responses of the
sub-game.
So what sub-game perfection
tells us to do here is first of
all, work out the new
equilibrium in the sub-game,
work out how much that new
equilibrium is worth for Firm A
and then roll it back to the
investment decision.
It turns out when we do that we
get an extra $.31 million.
So we could do it at home,
we get an extra $.31 million.
So it turns out that our MBA
student was right,
good.
It turns out that if you add
this .31 to the .69 we had
already we get 1,
which of course is much bigger
than .7 and indeed you should
rent the machine.
Now, I want you to have two
take away lessons from this
game.
The first take away lesson is
this.
When you're analyzing a game
like this, be it in the real
world or in a job interview,
the first thing you want to do
is what?
You want to look at the
sub-game.
You want to look at what would
happen if you did invest and
solve out the new Nash
equilibrium in that sub-game.
Then you want to roll back the
value of that sub-game back into
the initial decision which is
the strategic investment
decision whether to rent this
machine or not.
So schematically,
the game looks like this:
rent or not rent,
and in either case you play
Cournot.
There's a sub-game in each case.
In this case you play symmetric
Cournot, when you both have the
same costs;
and here you play asymmetric
Cournot, where you have
different costs.
And the way we analyze this
game is, we solve out the
symmetric Cournot,
we actually did that up front.
We now solve out the new
equilibrium in this asymmetric
Cournot game,
this one here.
This is the old one and this is
the new one.
Solve it out.
Work out how much profit you're
going to get.
And roll that back remembering
that it costs you $.7 million to
make this step.
So that's the first take away
lesson.
But the second take away lesson
is more general,
so let me just pause to get
everyone to wake up again so I
make it.
The second take away lesson is
this., What tips the balance
here from the Economics answer
and the accounting answer,
were the strategic effects.
It was the strategic effect.
This is a strategic effect.
It was the effect of the other
firm or other players changing
their behavior.
And the most common mistake to
make when you're thinking about
strategic decisions is what?
It's to forget that they're
strategic.
It's to forget that the other
players are going to change
their behavior.
In this example,
the other firm cuts back its
production so much as to make
that investment profitable.
But let me give you two other
examples.
Example number one.
You're designing a tax policy
for the U.S..
The dumb way to analyze this is
to say look at what people are
doing now, push through the new
tax numbers,
and act like an accountant and
crunch out how much money the
government's going to make.
Why is that wrong?
Because you're forgetting that
as you change the tax code
people's behavior changes.
Incentives change and people's
behavior changes.
It leads to a mistake in
designing the tax code.
You need to take into account
strategic effects:
how behavior changes.
Example number two,
closer to home.
You're designing a new
curriculum for Yale.
So you change the rules of the
curriculum and when analyzing it
you say--I wouldn't say this but
some people on the committee
might say this--under these new
rules,
if we look at what people used
to do, they will now do more of
this and less of that,
and they'll learn this and
learn that.
What are you missing?
You're missing that students
are players and students change
their behavior as you change the
curriculum rules.
So the biggest lesson of
today's class is don't be like
an accountant,
partly because it's boring and
you won't go on your date,
and partly because you'll miss
out on these important strategic
effects.
We'll come back and look at
more on Wednesday.